90 day fiance the other way continues
this october
have you ever cheated on me i just
wonder if there's
more going on that i don't know
i'm worried about my dad i just feel
like he's trying to avoid us
what am i doing with you what you want
me to wear
act right damn just accurate
he thinks that he's going to give me an
ultimatum but i'm gonna give
his ass the ultimatum he's not the king
of jordan
well i'm not asking you to give up on
your family i'm not gonna give up
even if you ask so are you sure that i'm
who you want to be with
very discouraging there's no respect to
that at all they're pretty much kicking
you in the teeth
you are going to deliver vicente we will
not wait
so when would i have to have the wave
today
what relax
i would like to know if you've been
having sex with somebody what for for my
own
sanity i don't think i need to tell you
if you don't baptize the baby goes to
heaven
you're gonna let your sisters talk to me
like this you act like
these eggs now i swear that's really
what's wrong with you it's my baby i
don't have anyone here i can talk to
it just makes me want to go home i must
be careful
it's dangerous how is it dangerous
there are people who genuinely hate him
now and
they might decide to kill him
[Music]
you